zu sagen dass nicht willkommen zur zdf
heute live noch ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und da ist gerade die frage wie kriegen
wir entspannte weihnachten trotz corona
hin denn für entspannte weihnachten sind
die infektionszahlen die wir zurzeit
haben immer noch zu hoch und deswegen
wird derzeit diskutiert ob am ende doch
nur ein harter lockdown das ist
zumindest eine forderung aus der
wissenschaft aber auch die politik
diskutiert seit spätestens heute darüber
ob nicht vielleicht doch alles dicht
gemacht werden muss wir wollen wir heute
schauen was ein harter lockt vielleicht
lockt dauern vielleicht bringen könnte
tatsächlich und zwar werden wir reden
mit professor thorsten leer der es
professor für klinische pharmazie an der
universität des saarlandes der hat mit
seinem team einen sogenannten kuhfuß
simulator entwickelt was das ist was er
kann das gucken wir uns gleich zusammen
mit dich hands-on hier an der kann quasi
berechnen welche maßnahmen wie was
bringen würden zumindest so ungefähr und
danach sprechende mit professor philip
rauschen nabel der es an der universität
der bundeswehr in münchen professor für
digitales marketing und mädchen in würde
und er hat dort eine weihnachts studie
gemacht hat quasi geguckt worauf freuen
sich menschen an weihnachten worauf
gucken sie und das ist in diesem
besonderen jahr tatsächlich auch sehr
außergewöhnlich und hat tatsächlich was
mit diesen lockdown maßnahmen zu tun
und die werden tatsächlich jetzt in
sachsen schon kommen das hat zumindest
ministerpräsident kretschmann
angekündigte hat gesagt ab montag wird
das land runtergefahren wir schauen mal
was dort genau beschlossen wurde und
verkündet wurde
cornelia schiemenz hat das ganze für uns
zusammengefasst lange hat sachsens
ministerpräsident noch gehofft dass die
zahlen wieder nach unten gehen dass die
menschen eigenverantwortlich und
vernünftig sind
heute nun die notbremse ab montag geht
der ganze freistaat in den kompletten
lockdown damit kehrt die ruhe um
weihnachten und den jahreswechsel im
freistaat sachsen in diesem jahr etwas
früher ein als sonst
wir haben uns vorgenommen dass die
maßnahmen bis zum 10 januar gelten
sollen ein auf der einen seite
überschaubarer zeitraum und trotzdem
eine herausforderung
vier wochen stille keine schule keine
kita kein shopping die masten pflicht
überall im öffentlichen raum menschen
sollen zu hause bleiben weil sachsens
kliniken am limit sind im
helios-klinikum frei teiligen heute mehr
als 70 patienten so viele wie noch nie
es ist notwendig diesen lockdown einfach
zu machen weil wir können einfach auf
dauer hier im landkreis aber auch im
umfeld in sachsen mit diesem fall zahlen
im gesundheitssystem einfach nicht
weiter umgehen weihnachten im lockdown
da tröstet auch die prächtige tanne auf
dem dresdner altmarkt nur wenig ja das
erste bundesland macht also wieder dicht
ist das der richtige schritt das möchte
ich mit euch mit ihnen diskutieren wie
immer gerne in den dafür vorgesehen und
kommentarspalten und mit professor
thorsten leer der ist professor für
klinische pharmazie an der universität
des saarlandes hallo ein wunder schicken
und sie haben so ein ja profit simulator
programmiert den man übrigens jeder im
netz ausprobieren kann gucken das gleich
mal an
aber vielleicht können sie zunächst mal
sagen wie zuverlässig können sie
tatsächlich vorhersagen oder voraus
berechnet was solche maßnahmen wie in
sachsen jetzt bringen können
ja also wir können uns dafür ein
bisschen auf die vergangenheit berufen
wer hat betreiben jetzt diesen simulator
eigentlich seit märz und berechnen
seitdem eigentlich die die effekte die
auch stattfinden das heißt also diese
nicht fahrzeuges maßnahmen die
schulschließung und ähnliches und können
daraus dann halt auch ableiten
also wenn ich zukünftig erwarten werden
das heißt also wir hoffen natürlich
schon dass wir einigermaßen präzise uns
annähern können was wir erwarten aber
ein zweiter faktor den wir nicht
vergessen dürfen ist natürlich auch wie
sehr hält sich eigentlich die
bevölkerung daran was für maßnahmen
vorgegeben werden welche parameter haben
sie darf mit rein gearbeitet also was
das quasi der wichtige wert auf dem sie
sich stützen oder gibt es da
verschiedene also unser modell gehen
relativ viele verschiedene werte ein wir
haben ganz viele daten die dann mit
einfließen aus ganz vielen verschiedenen
quellen
wichtig jetzt für die fragestellung wie
jetzt gerade interessiert ist eben genau
diese frage wie sich diese basis
reproduktions zahl eigentlich reduzieren
wird und dauert fragen wir quasi immer
das modell wie weit bestimmte ereignisse
die schulschließung oder ähnliches denn
ein effekt auch diese reduktion hat und
das können wir dann entsprechend
ableiten und das überträgt sich dann
halt eben auch über die fallzahlen in
richtung der krankenhaus eingewiesenen
patienten intensiv patienten wie viele
auch versterben das heißt dass er das
hilft uns dann im großen und ganzen das
bild ganzheitlich zu betrachten
dann wollen wir doch mal wissen damit
herumspielen mit ihrem simulator ich hab
den hier bei mir auf den rechner
aufgemacht das könnt ihr und sie können
das zuhause auch machen die adresse ist
gut - simulator punkt kommt und dann
wird man auf diese seite hier geleitet
die die kollegen jetzt vielleicht mal
aufmachen können bei mir ist oder sieht
man sie und da geht man tatsächlich hier
einfach auf simulator
ich musste noch mal kurz komplett
erlauben so und dann müsste sich das
öffnen hier loading simulator ich sage
hier und dann gebt das fenster hier auf
das sieht auf den ersten blick so ein
bisschen technisch aus professor lehr
sie können das hier auch sehen auf ihrem
rechner können sie mal kurz sagen was
ich jetzt genau hier vor mir sehe also
oben links region da kann ich genau
richtig
man kann genau richtigen kann sich also
quasi das bundesland auswählen wir
können aber auch bei gesamt deutschland
bleiben und wir haben dann wenn wir uns
ein bundesland aussuchen wenn sie sich
jetzt sein bundesland aussuchen bayern
sachsen und sachsen zum beispiel darin
sich die sich letztendlich auf den
landkreis noch aussuchen falls ihr das
spezifische landkreis durchführen wollen
also wir haben uns auch für alle 412
stadt und landkreise durchgeführt wenn
sie allerdings nur bei einem gesamten
bundesland bleiben wollen machen wir das
bundesland so wie wir das mögen also
schon technisch ist das ja gar nicht
darunter ist jetzt die eiskappe city das
ist die intensivbetten kapazität 735 ist
jetzt für sachsen hier schon
voreingestellt das ist richtig ja genau
also wir wir schauen dann immer am tage
der aktualisierung wie die maximale
bettenzahl ist die vom intensiv register
ausgegeben wird da muss man natürlich
bedenken dass die bettenzahl an sich
auch nicht unbedingt das ist was an
freien betten existiert sondern
personalmangel kann sich die zahlen
entsprechen doch noch reduzieren aber
das ist ungefähr der richtwert den wir
heute annehmen werden dennoch an freien
und ein insgesamt betten vorhanden ist
richtig so und jetzt habe ich hier so
ein schalter dasteht future
das ist wahrscheinlich genau dieser
erwert dieser in für diese reproduktions
zahl ich blicke den schalter mal um
genau ich sehe mich den schalte sind wir
jetzt in der möglichkeit die möglichkeit
einfach zu sagen ich möchte gern ein
szenario verändern also wie das jetzt in
sachsen laufen wird dann ab dem 14
dezember kann man sich das datum dann
aussuchen abgedreht sind im dezember
dann mache ich genau den 14 dezember
statt stelle ich mal ein so dass wir den
man nehmen was ist denn da ja also ich
denke in realistischer ärgert von harten
lockdown ist jetzt unsere vermutung dass
der zwischen 0,6 und 0,7 liegen weil das
ist das was in der ersten welle gesehen
haben bei einem sehr harten lockdown und
das was wir auch aus anderen ländern
gesehen haben also aus italien
frankreich spanien ungefähr die region
wo wir erwarten dass wir wirklich bei
schließung von schulen nur noch
öffnungen von relevanten an geschäften
dass wir dort eigentlich leben langen
werden auf den blechen aber dieser wehrt
er bricht ja nicht sofort in sich
zusammen sondern der singt ja auch mit
der zeit ist das auch mit einberechnet
also wir gehen jetzt im moment erstmal
von einem konstanten ärgert aus das
problem dass wir so ein bisschen haben
ist dass sich manchmal diese er gehörte
auch ein bisschen schon vorher
einstellen das haben wir gesehen dass
ich manchmal auch schon mit einer
ankündigung von mlog down sich schon
reduziert weil haben die bürgerinnen und
bürger eine gewisse respekt vor der
situation bekommt und manchmal sehen wir
auch das ist eine gewisse nachschärfung
gewinnen die begrünung bürger dann
merken dass es jetzt ernst wird das ist
ein bisschen quasi noch einmal
nachjustiert werden muss in dem
simulator haben wir jetzt einfach
gehalten das wird natürlich nur eine
feststellung möglichkeit haben aber ich
denke für die für die für dieses
szenario zu betrachten sollte das
eigentlich erst mal ausreichen also
quasi den jahren lasse ich das mal so
bei 0,65 habe ich erst mal gesagt dass
wir quasi die zielvorgabe jetzt gehört
die zeit einstellen hier simulations-
zeit von was haben wir jetzt januar 2020
ist schon vorbei da waren wir alle noch
unschuldig und unwissend ich nehme jetzt
mal tatsächlich hier den dreizehnter und
dann simuliert das mal bis zum 31
dezember und jetzt drücke ich mal auf
den knopf bringen etwas passiert so und
da haben wir jetzt schöne kurven
einmal die kumulierten zahl fall zahlen
zahlen zahlen so und da sehen wir also
trotzdem geht die kurve immer noch hoch
obwohl wir ein r wert unter 1 haben aber
nicht mehr so doll oder bin ich genau
die kumulierten die kumulierten sammeln
jahr alle zusammen das ist vielleicht
momentan die guten attraktivste kurve
weil sie eine gewisse negativität aus
streit weil sie im rad steigt haben sie
können maximal flach werden oder
ansteigen was soll ich denn jetzt machen
wir weiter wir gehen mal ein bisschen
was darunter genau wir können auch noch
noch ein weiter runter wo dann die
aktuellen fallzahlen kommen naja da geht
nur kurz runter ok toll hier geht die
kurve unter hier können sie jetzt die
rote kurve spiel quasi die die
fallzahlen da die tägliche fallzahlen
bei uns ist es jetzt der schnitt also
wir vermitteln dass dann quasi über die
woche hinweg man weiß ja dass über die
woche alles gewisse schwankungen gibt
und dann können wir hier letztendlich
ablesen wie viele fälle wir haben werden
man kann auch nur die rote kurve
anklicken indem man die anderen
ausschalteten sind so kleine häkchen im
blauen lassen sie ihre krawatten und die
toten können sie ausschalten genau und
dann hat man so diese kurven dann können
wir genau sehen wo wir denn dann
eigentlich landen werden und da sehen so
das ist hier so oben roten unten rot ist
dass das quasi so die der spielraum den
sie sich in all diesem rechenmodell
erlauben genau richtig also das ist
letztlich eine reduktion sind dabei was
er dann erwarten basieren dorf
unsicherheiten die natürlich in seine
modelle mit drin stecken
ähnlich wie dies bei der
wettervorhersage auch kennen haben
natürlich dann auch dort schwankungen
mit einem rechnet werner selbst hier
sehen wir die pfalz halten und immer so
gemittelt würden wir dann hier nächste
woche anfangen bei 3000 5 neue
infizierten positiv getesteten menschen
und würden dann am 31
ein bisschen irritieren dass unten
dezember 20 steht aber hier ist nur noch
31 da sind wir bei 1200 also schon
deutlich mehr als halbierung der
täglichen fallzahlen ja genau und jetzt
kann ich auch noch erstmalig mal die
böse kurve an die mit den todeszahlen
und die steigt aber nochmal an weil die
menschen halt erst im laufe der
erkrankung versterben mehr richtig
genauso wie berechnen ja eben auch was
passiert im krankenhaus neben
nachstellen
nach der infektion kommen natürlich
erstmal ein schwerer verlauf der dann
möglicherweise eben im krankenhaus endet
und dann dort ist versterben eine
gewisse verzögerung quasi eintritt also
das heißt selbst wenn wir jetzt sofort
bremsen diverser noch weiteren anstieg
erst mal von rote zahlen möglicherweise
nicht wirklich weiter sondern sehr
wahrscheinlich erleben
aber die flammen dann kann man hier
sehen um den a7 und zwanzigster dezember
fällt die kurve dann wieder deutlich ab
also es gibt dann immer weniger
es gibt es ja schon die erste kritik
sehe ich gerade mit einem auge auf
facebook habe ich gesehen
ein kommentar von marcel für wollt ihr
weiterhin die fallzahlen ohne bezugswert
der durchgeführten tests als indikator
nehmen ob wir das land lahmlegen haben
sie das tatsächlich da auch mit
berücksichtigt wie viele tests
durchgeführt werden und dann anhand der
fallzahlen das ganze versucht durch zu
rechnen
ja und nein also in diesem momentan
aktuell vorhandenen online simulator
sind die fallzahlen nur implizit mit
drin in dem wir das zum beispiel
veränderliche hospitalisierung traten in
jetzt haben sie das heißt der schwere
verlauf ändert sich über die zeit
dagegen die fallzahl mit ein
wir arbeiten gerade oder haben eine
version 2 fertig gestellt wo die
fallzahlen bzw die test positiv rate mit
implizit eingebaut ist er arbeitet von
performance her genauso gut wie der der
jetzt haben ist aber von der methode
kein bisschen besser erklären
gut dann schauen wir mal weiter es gibt
glaube ich noch einen anderen einmal die
hospitalisierung kurve haben wir hier
auch noch die auch dann leicht steigt
noch mal also verzögert quasi mit dem
lock down bis zum 25
dezember steigt sie und dann geht es ein
bisschen runter und ganz ungenügend ist
noch die sieben tage incidents das ist
dann wieder dieser mittelwert 7 also wie
viele wie viele hundert erkrankter pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen so
genau so dass genau das sind genau wo in
sieben tagen und das ist ja das ziel das
wir hier eigentlich unter die marke von
mindestens 50 kommen und was man hier
eigentlich will sachsen sieht dass das
höchstwahrscheinlich relativ schwierig
wird also bis zum ende des jahres halte
ich das für sachsen für recht
unwahrscheinlich ich kann jetzt auf
ihrem bildschirm gerade die zahl nicht
lesen wo wir landen
58,5 am ende am 31
also da ist noch luft nach unten genau
das ist ja sportlich also da müssen wir
natürlich die simulation noch weiter
fortführen also dass meine simulation
ich vorhin von sachsen mal gemacht aber
das war das ungefähr bis ende januar
eigentlich durchhalten müssen und ist
natürlich ein sehr langer zeitraum ist
dass man nicht vergessen und das im
januar müsste das land komplett in
bockhorn gehen ja hier genauso wie sie
können das datum letztendlich mal auf
ende januar weiter die fragen kann man
ganz schnell beantworten und dann nehme
hier dann auch mal diesen future er muss
sich wieder anpassen 0,65 dann sachlich
simulations- zeit von 13
dezember bis 31 januar so wenn es nicht
mal gespannt was dann rauskommt kann man
fast miteinander so in der sohn
konferenz machen also wenn man abends
nicht weiß was man machen soll man kann
nicht in die kneipe gehen sagt man
kommen wir hängen uns mal wohl in kopie
simulator ersten mal durch was passieren
würde wenn genaue analysen so in
apokalyptischen szenarien richtig wenn
wir ganz ganz runter gehen genau dann
sehen wir letztendlich das ist hier dann
doch noch weiter runter gehen wird
wie gesagt ich kenne die zahlen leider
nicht erkennen auf ihrem bildschirm ist
ja auch nicht sagen genau was sie gesagt
haben 28 jahren aber sind wir bei 58 auf
100000 und dann die gewünschte zahl
erreichen wird tatsächlich erst am 31
januar
das würde tatsächlich heißen sachsen
müsste komplett die nächsten anderthalb
monate in so einem harten locker angehen
das halte ich für schwierig politisch
vermittelbar dann tatsächlich unter
diesem wert von 50 zu kommen
so jetzt wo wir ja deutschland
vielleicht rechnen
was ist denn da also wir können ja mal
schauen wenn wir quasi so weitermachen
wie bisher also mit den maßnahmen die
wir gerade haben wir nennen das ja im
fachjargon ein shutdown an leichten
schatten einen partiellen stadt darum
quasi in der wohnung manche gewerbe zu
machen dann würden sie mir was empfehlen
also ich sag region deutschland die
ganze region
da haben sie vorher eingestellt an
intensivbetten kapazität 9620 und wir
sind gerade bei einem ungefähren wert
von 1,02 das heißt das lassen wir
einfach mal so stehen ja das ist quasi
das was gerade aktuell ist genau wenn
wir das so lassen in deutschland dann
werden wir relativ flach
einfach erleben das heißt also wir
werden einfach so eine seitwärtsbewegung
erleben was die fallzahlen dann geht das
heißt wir werden uns bis weihnachten
ungefähr bei also 18.000 fälle im
schnitt täglich ein norden müssen und
die inzidenz würden noch ganz knapp 150
fälle pro sieben tage pro 100000
einwohner liegen also auch extrem hoch
aber jetzt nicht so hoch wie das was
jetzt momentan in sachsen haben und
letztendlich goethe-institut so stehen
wir uns gerade bewegen träger dann
natürlich auch wie lange nicht dieser
shutter und anhalten muss das befinden
uns wirklich sehr hoch auf einem niveau
wie bei spielzeug in sachsen
dann müssen wir das eben entsprechend
auch länger durchhalten diesen blog
dauer und der sehen wir halt eben auch
dass ich habs jetzt leser aufgerufen
tägliche fallzahlen ist tatsächlich also
man gerade kurve fängt an jetzt heutigen
tag achter dezember bei 18.500 55 fällen
also oben ist macht manchmal kann die
recovered aus das ist ein bisschen
irritierend so also trinkt bei 18.500 55
an hier unten und wie gesagt kann man
das einen aus klicken und wir bleiben
stabil bei 18.000 ungefähr bis ende
januar ab bewegt sich quasi gar nichts
aber erfahren der frage warum gibt es
denn hier so hohe ausschläge oben und
unten bei der roten kurve
ja also die unsicherheit ist natürlich
ähnlich wie bei der wettervorhersage
weiter wegen die zukunft gucken und
unsichere wird dass das heißt also da
kriegen wir an unseren scheren artigen
blick den wir jetzt hier eben auch sehen
weil natürlich jetzt auch wir müssen wir
bedenken sind natürlich szenarien und
die frage wird halt sein bleibt das
wirklich so und deswegen ist da die
unsicherheit entsprechend dann auch
zunehmend also das ist eine
mathematische effekte mir einfach sehen
also ich habe hier ein paar fragen
gerade schon rein gereicht bekommen aus
der zuschauerschaft trader möchte wissen
kann man damit jeden ort simulieren oder
sind die bundesländer vorgegeben ich
habe schon gesehen
sie gehen bis auf die landkreise runter
tatsächlich genau richtig wir können das
bis auf die landkreise runter wir haben
das jetzt nicht kleiner als die
landkreise weil die anderen daten wenig
bekommen aber wir haben eben alle 412
stadt und landkreise drin und sagen
letztendlich auch vorher was dort
eigentlich auf den in den krankenhäusern
passieren würde da muss man partiell ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein wir sehen dass
das auch sehr gut funktioniert die
vorhersage für die krankenhäuser dort
aber nicht jeder landkreis hat
krankenhäuser dass sie gewisse migration
wenn sie sehr ländliche region haben
dann zieht das die manchmal in die
umliegenden stadtteilen sie dann rein so
aber prinzip funktioniert das auch sehr
gut
stefanie stärken möchte noch mal wissen
wo kann man das tool finden die adresse
ist co witt - im simulator also
simulator punkt kommen cupid wie es
geschrieben wird mit dvi d - simulator
punkt kommt da kann man sich das
anschauen und titel bürger möchte wissen
warum werden fallzahlen infektionszahlen
überhaupt diskutiert sind die nicht
irreführend da es im endeffekt immer
darum geht wie viele leute in
intensivstationen sind und ich glaube da
können wir noch mal hier auf den
seminaren simulator gehen und das wird
ja auch genau hier abgebildet genau
richtig da lohnt sich vielleicht dass
man mal die dass man die krankenhäuser
völlig mal weg macht krankenhaus
kapazität ist wahrscheinlich nicht das
problem das problem sind die patienten
und genau deswegen habe ich den
simulator natürlich auch nicht nur um
die fallzahlen sondern eben auch um die
krankenhaus kapazität und krankenhaus
bewegung eingefroren dass er jetzt
momentan sehen ist ich gehe eigentlich
davon aus dass sie jetzt in den nächsten
tagen noch einen stärkeren anstieg sehen
wir einen momentan sehen wir das in den
fallzahlen beim intensiv register dass
die belebung wieder stark ansteigen also
das ist ein etwas google szenario und
was wir halt eben aussehen ist das
deutschlandweit wir gewisse unterschiede
sehen was was die belastung angeht also
bundesländer weit aber gibt es einfach
bundesländer in denen die auslastung
größer ist als in anderen also da müssen
wir diesen fall realismus immer noch
bedenken wenn man nur gesamt deutschland
anschauen dann sehe ich hier ich habe ja
nochmal einmal durchgerechnet was
passiert wenn jetzt nichts machen quasi
das einfach so weiterlaufen lassen dann
sehe ich hier bei den hospitalisierungen
das ist ja genau das was man anklicken
kann und ein intensivbetten und auch
wenn teenager also auch beatmet das ist
eigentlich nur kurve die so weiter läuft
die ganze zeit also es geht immer so um
die 4000 personen auf intensivstation
und davon zweieinhalbtausend ungefähr
beatmet also eigentlich könnten ja so
weitermachen weil es gibt es keine
großartiger überlastung also zumindest
wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht dass es gar
wenn ich komplett zusammengebrochen ist
das system wird man so betrachtet ist
richtig was wir weil es gibt sachen die
wir nicht vergessen dürfen was momentan
in dieser aktuellen version vom
simulator noch nicht drin ist dass die
altersstruktur hier in dem fall fix
angenommen wird das heißt wenn wir jetzt
mehr ältere patienten haben die sich
infizieren und das ist ein phänomen das
wir gerade sehen wenn auch wieder mehr
ins krankenhaus gehen und sich auch am
ende des tages wieder mehr versterben
das heißt das ist jetzt in der version 2
die wir gerade online dann demnächst zur
verfügung stellen kann man das dann auch
mit berücksichtigen und berechnen
aber wichtig ist vor allem sie haben es
eigentlich gerade indirekt auch schon
gesagt ist wir sind zwar auf einem
steady-state das ungleichgewicht was die
krankenhäuser angeht und intensivstation
habe uns sterben natürlich jeden tag
auch mindestens 250 bis 300 patienten
und personal hat das mal wirklich mit
der der masters jeden tag einen
flugzeugabsturz
das darf man einfach nicht vergessen da
kommen wir dann natürlich innerhalb
eines monats auch schnell auf zehn bis
15.000 tote und das ist natürlich die
frage ob wir das natürlich tolerieren
wollen das darf man einfach nicht
vergessen ja ich habe hier noch mal die
todes kurve aufgerufen quasi die dann
sie sich jetzt hier berechnet haben wenn
wir einfach weitermachen wie bisher dann
pendelt sich das so bei 301 aber es kann
natürlich sieht man hier nach oben und
unten das lied ist luft nach oben und
unten man muss natürlich mit berechnen
hier irgendwann wird es geht es dann
gegen weihnachten und danach kann
natürlich noch mehr passieren so es gibt
hier mal wieder harte diskussionen in
den kommentaren wie immer meine bitte um
sachlichkeit und man muss sich nicht
gegenseitig beleidigen
einige bezweifeln mal wieder komplett
das ist richtig ist was wir hier
berechnen und dass die zahlen stimmen
ich glaube diese diskussion führen wir
jetzt hier nicht
karin buchholz fordert hier das schreibt
hier alle ministerpräsidenten die sich
dem kurs von bayern und sachsen nicht
anschließend tragen die verantwortung
für das was passiert also 500 tote
täglich
also bis zu 500 tote haben wir
tatsächlich gerade teilweise dieter
rascals schreibt so ein bisschen
ironisch die vorhersage funktioniert wie
die wettervorhersage
ja das ist tatsächlich das hatten sie
gerade schon gesagt ein bisschen
abhängig davon wie die menschen sich
verhalten
richtig das ist natürlich ein faktor in
dem bin ich drin stecken ja also aber
auch die wettervorhersage ist ja nicht
um präzise also zumindest wenn man sich
aber nicht über wenn wir jetzt nicht
fragen wie zum beispiel ostern werden
wird aber ich denke eine prognose für
weiße weihnachten kann man heute schon
in einer gewissen zuverlässigkeit
stellen und so ist das hier natürlich
auch wir haben natürlich immer szenario
nun gewisse annahmen dafür ist dieses
tool natürlich besonders gut auch für
die politik um abzuwägen was würde denn
passieren weil es ein so komplexer
zusammenhang ist diese angenehme der wir
uns hier befassen
dass wir am ende des tages natürlich
hier über solche tools einfach auch mal
visualisieren können berechnen können
was würde passieren wenn und das nicht
erst mal ausprobieren müssen oben dann
vier wochen später zu merken dass es
eigentlich nicht funktioniert so jetzt
haben sie gar schon gesagt die menschen
müssen sich daran halten die politik
kann sich an diesen tools orientieren
aber es gibt aus der wissenschaft auch
sehr klare forderungen was als nächstes
passieren soll zum beispiel und von dem
wissenschaftlichen rat den mitgliedern
aber einigen miteinander nationalen
akademie der wissenschaften leopoldina
die haben einen dringlichen appell an
die politik heute gerichtet und die
haben unter anderem dass sie gefordert
die wissenschaftsakademie leopoldina
fordert eine verschärfung der korona
beschränkungen in drei schritten schon
ab kommendem montag will das institut
das die schulpflicht aufgehoben wird bis
zu den ferien kurz vor weihnachten in
einem zweiten schritt ab heiligabend
soll dann ein harter shutdown kommen
heißt alle geschäfte schließen außer
etwa supermärkte und apotheken home
office müsse möglichst die regel sein
soziale kontakte sind extrem
einzuschränken gelten soll das bis
mindestens zum zehnten januar ab dann
gibt es wenn es nach der leopoldina geht
eine masten pflicht in der schule in
allen jahrgangsstufen wie gesagt dass
alles bis jetzt nur forderungen
professor der sie haben diesen kuwait
simulator mit ihrem team programmiert
sind dass forderungen den sie sich
anschließen können oder die sich
zumindest nachvollziehen können anhand
der daten er absolut das sind also auf
forderungen die ich auch schon mit
unserer staatskanzlei diskutiert habe
und ich denke das wird absolut notwendig
sein dass wir eigentlich möglichst rasch
jetzt wirklich auf die bremse treten wir
befinden uns so viel wirklich einem sehr
hohen niveau
und wenn wir diese lockerung auch wieder
etwas aufheben wollen mitte januar dann
müssen wir jetzt gleich anfangen
ansonsten werden wir das ähnlich wie das
was wir vorher in sachsen gesehen haben
nicht in dem endlichen zeitrahmen
hinbekommen und ich glaube das ist
einfach wichtig für die bevölkerung auf
zu lesen weil eine gewisse
erwartungshaltung natürlich an diese
aussagen der politiker geknüpft sind
damit sind ja mal gespannt ob sich da
was bewegt die diskussion ist ja in
vollem gange für heute abend aber
erstmal vielen sein professor für ihre
ansichten und ihren tollen simulator
denen ich sage es nochmal sich jeder
angucken kann im netz kuwait - simulator
punkt kommen da könnt ihr einmal mit
rumspielen vielen dank dankeschön
also ich gucke einfach in die kommentare
da wird munter diskutiert zum beispiel
hier auf youtube com beschreibt eine
frechheit man wollte bewusst den
showdown zu weihnachten und silvester
einen locker und hätte man schon
november machen können das ist glaube
ich eine etwas schwierige behauptung
lieber tonnen ich glaube nicht dass
irgendjemand bewusst dass wollte
zumindest sehe ich dafür überhaupt keine
indizien
dann gibt es hier noch einen kommentar
von k s ein harter lockdown hilft nur
mit anschließendem tracking neuer fälle
sonst geht es wieder von vorne los warum
haben alle angst nach asien schrägstrich
neuseeland zu schauen da ist die
wirtschaft die da oben hier gab es auch
einen entsprechenden kommentar auf
facebook habe ich schon gesehen da wurde
gefragt warum denn in china alles
funktioniert warum man sich da nicht
quasi hilfe geholt hat und ich glaube
das kann man damit beantworten dass dort
eben sehr stark und sehr vehement
getrackt wird dass die apps die es dort
auch gibt's zum größten teil
verpflichtet sind und menschen mit einem
negativen start ups teilweise wirklich
14 tage in harte quarantäne geschickt wo
erwerben die dann auch bewacht wird und
das sind alles maßnahmen die werden hier
im allgemeinen nicht ganz so gerne
gesehen aber die frage ist jetzt wie
werden die maßnahmen diskutiert gesehen
die in sachsen jetzt kommen sollen ab
nächste woche wir haben mal in sachsen
auf der straße gefragt
wenn wir irgendwann wieder normalität
erreichen wollen dann ist es vielleicht
besser wenn wir das jetzt wieder machen
als wenn wir zu lange damit warten
wir wollen dass er alle sterben und
krank sind nur das ist doch richtig
gesund bleiben verwaltung mit 90 zu
hause
die sollen wir uns geht weihnachten
erleben sitzen es hätte ja was passieren
soll
ja also eigentlich alles relativ
befürwortende stimmen
es könnte was damit zu tun haben dass da
eine kamera vor ihnen stand aber das
wird uns jetzt genauer beantworten
professor philip raus schnabel von der
bundeswehr universität in münchen
professor für digitales marketing und
medien innovation
der hat nämlich zum dritten mal jetzt
eine weihnachts studie durchgeführt und
hat dort eigentlich mal wissen wollen
wie menschen weihnachten feiern und über
weihnachten denken hat aber natürlich in
diesem jahr auch sich mit krone
beschäftigen müssen hallo herr ausgabe
hallo so sie haben auch und das finde
ich jetzt tatsächlich für unsere
diskussion mit am wichtigsten gefragt ob
sich die menschen an die abstandsregeln
halten wollen was ist dabei
herausgekommen
eigentlich ein paar ganz interessante
sachen wir haben einerseits
herausgefunden dass ein großteil der
menschen diesen beschränkungen oder
diesen regularien sehr positiv
gegenübersteht
dann müsste man auch denken dass er
nicht wirklich fast alle leute sich auch
an diese regeln halten möchten
nee ist nicht so also sind über 40
prozent der befragten die angeben dass
sie zumindest bereit wären diese
regularien an weihnachten zu umgehen
oder zu missachten
wie kommt denn das jetzt also das ist ja
irgendwie paradox einerseits sagen ich
will die regeln gut und man sollte sie
durchhalten haben wir auch gerade vor
der kamera gesehen andererseits sagt was
die hälfte ohne mitmachen mache ich
nicht das ist in der tat ein paradox das
ist aber was was man auch aus anderen
situationen kennt gibt verschiedene
erklärungsansätze dafür so dass einer
ist wenn man over confident spies und
das drückt letztendlich aus dass
menschen der meinung sind solche regeln
sind wichtig weil der normale bürger
sich da das er braucht solche regeln
ansonsten klappt das nicht aber ich kann
das einschätzen
und dieser ist natürlich falsch wenn das
alle leute denken aber das ist ein
klassischer fehler den man im bei der
wahrnehmung von solchen komplexen
situationen ganz häufig hat er dass man
seine eigenen fähigkeiten überschätzt
und sagte ich
zwar gut das ist die regeln gibt aber
ich selber mache daneben da mal ein
bisschen raus aber 42 links schon
ziemlich hoch halten sie die zahl für
realistisch oder ist das tatsächlich
noch eine dunkelziffer dabei das ist
vielleicht sogar noch mehr sein könnten
ich glaube die dunkelziffer ist deutlich
höher zum einen hat man bei befragungen
die sogenannte soziale erwünschtheit
also menschen antworten so wie sich das
gehört ja so man antwortet er so den
normen und gesetzen sagen und es
vielleicht ein bisschen gehemmt auch
zusagen nicht recht die regeln und das
zweite ist weihnachten ist ein sehr
emotionales fest und emotionalen
situationen verhält man sich nicht
unbedingt rational da kennt jeder
bestimmt aus dem alltag viele beispiele
wo das genau so ist vor allem wenn man
dann sieht dass sich doch ein großteil
der leute vielleicht nicht dran hält
dann kommt ein sogenanntes hohen normen
verhaltenen herdentrieb von menschen
dass man sich an diesem verhalten
anpasst und sagt na ja wenn die anderen
die regeln brechen und sich treffen dann
muss ich mich ja nicht zurück halten
dann kann das ja nicht so schlimm sein
und das trifft auf ganz viele menschen
zu es ist ein sehr starker mechanismus
und deswegen glaube ich dass die
dunkelziffer deutlich höher liegt
wer hält sich denn jetzt ihr nicht daran
oder wer hat er gesagt ich hab keine
lust haben mitzumachen konnten sie das
auch aus dieser befragung heraus
kristallisieren ja wir sind schon das
dass er junge menschen sind die da offen
sind sich diese diesen regularien zu
widersetzen
ja vor allen dingen so unter 40 rückte
den unter 40-jährigen generell und dann
je älter die menschen werden desto eher
erhalten sie sich auch die regeln kann
man das sind sie begründen oder haben
sie das nicht abgefragt
wir haben das nicht explizit abgefragt
aber wie ich gehe davon aus das ist
natürlich davon damit zusammenhängt dass
junge menschen eher weniger risiko
gefährdet sind ältere menschen jüngere
menschen sind auch eher hedonistisch
veranlagt das heißt die legen er wert
darauf auf dinge die spaß machen und
nicht immer ganz rational wobei
paradoxerweise auch hier junge menschen
zum beispiel auch politische
entscheidungen tendenziell eher positiv
bewerten jetzt hat jetzt ein kommentar
der paste wissen zu ihrer studie ist ich
gerade im markus bruder usb weiß ich
nicht weihnachten 2009 10 auch nur
weihnachten steht vor der tür da habe
ich die bucklige verwandtschaft eine
bake weihnachten 2020 so ein mist jetzt
darf ich mich mal
nicht nicht mal mit meiner
verwandtschaft treffen diktatur
ausrufezeichen
ist das so ein bisschen was was sie auch
mitgekriegt haben in ihrer befragung wie
die menschen jetzt auch weihnachten
dieses jahr gucken ja also
weihnachtsfeste weihnachts
verpflichtungen sind so eine art
hassliebe bei menschen also wenn man
weihnachtsfest der hat große
familienfeste dann empfindet man das als
sehr stressig und denkt hoffentlich ist
bald wieder rum wenn man es aber nicht
hat dann sagt man es fehlt aber noch ein
elementarer teil
grundsätzlich sehen wir aber und das ist
glaube ich eine sehr positive nachricht
an die bevölkerung dass menschen sehr
optimistisch sind dass viele menschen
der meinung sind wir machen aus dem
weihnachten trotzdem das beste draus es
wird schon werden
es wird zwar anders aber es wird
trotzdem schön und die erwartungen sind
sehr niedrig und niedrige erwartungen
sind immer gut wenn niedrige erwartungen
kann man sehr leicht haben auch
erreichen oder sogar übertreffen
das heißt im endeffekt hat das ganze
jetzt auch so ein bisschen den positiven
effekt dass das so den druck
rausgenommen wurde aus diesem jahr
manchmal doch sehr anstrengenden
weihnachtsfest wo alle irgendwie denken
da muss als solide freude eierkuchen
herrschen drei tage lang und alle müssen
sich ganz doll lieb haben und sa 10
pfennig genau die erwartungen gehen
einfach rückt also die
erwartungshaltungen trifft sind weniger
menschen man muss für weniger menschen
etwas vorbereiten
man hat viel weniger verpflichtet
weniger stress leute können also viel
entspannter an das weihnachtsfest
angehen und das ist auch so mein tipp
eigentlich also machen sie das beste
draus weil das ist ein weihnachten das
wird bestimmt in 20 jahren noch in
erinnerung bleiben dass das sind ja noch
so gutes und nachrichten aus der studie
können sie doch irgendwie noch was mit
geben so wir denken okay vielleicht ist
doch nicht alles so schlimm wie manche
gerade jetzt denken oder dass er auch
oft gesagt wird in den medien
ich glaube weihnachten wird dieses jahr
schön also es gibt deutlich deutlich
weniger stress die leute haben sind sind
entspannter gehen an das thema lockere
rang freuen sich trotzdem drauf auch was
geschenke angeht geht viel der trend
richtung persönlichen dingen
ich würde auf jeden fall versuchen
dieses weihnachten nicht unnötig
streitig zu machen mit anderen sachen
also ich würde zum beispiel auch
irgendwie ein ausgefallenes essen
verzichten wird lieber was einfaches
machen zeit mit der familie verbringen
wie vielleicht nie irgendwas anderes
überlegen was man vielleicht sonst an
weihnachten typischerweise nicht macht
und wirklich optimistisch an die sache
ran gehen und sagen
muss nicht jedes jahr gleich sein
weihnachten kann auch mal anders sein
kann auch mit weniger kontakten schön
sein und dann glaube ich wird das
trotzdem ein schönes fest so hier gibt
es leichte beschwerden über die
ergebnisse ihrer studie schreibt nämlich
ein kommentator auf youtube so ein
schwachsinn ich bin 24 und ich treffe
mich nur noch mit meiner freundin und
mit meinen eltern das sind nicht die
jungen menschen
ich glaube da muss man ja einfach sagen
das kann man nicht verallgemeinern aber
sie haben wahrscheinlich weil wir sehen
nur die tendenz dass es bei jungen
menschen ein größerer anteil ist
zwischen 50 und 60
die das jetzt schon angeben das heißt
aber nicht dass das alle sind das ist
also ganz klar
jetzt sind sie auch professor für
marketing wie kann man denn jetzt diese
maßnahmen vielleicht auch teilweise
diesen harten lockdown so verkaufen dass
viele menschen auch bereit sind
tatsächlich mitzumachen
also zum einen ist es glaube ich
schlecht zu sagen man erlaubt irgendwas
und nimmt das dann wieder zurück weil
das ist so eine lossa version nennt man
das also mal läuft und es gibt doch
nimmt das ihn wieder weg wird das
normalerweise sehr negativ die
kommunikation sollte man anpassen ja
also viele transparenter und auch jack
einfühlsam mal auch kommunizieren die
leute noch besser erklären warum man was
macht ja auch ganz klar sagen wir machen
das nicht um irgend jemand zu ärgern
oder irgendjemand was böses zu tun
sondern wir müssen das machen niemand
hat lust drauf
ja man kann sich zum beispiel auch
überlegen ob man ja dass man leute dazu
bringt auch untereinander auf sich ein
bisschen zu achten dass man also wenn
man sieht man jemand hält sich nicht an
die regeln ist meine freunde auch ganz
gezielt darauf anspricht ist
parteiübergreifend auch kommuniziert und
genau das heißt dass im endeffekt im
endeffekt ist jeder jetzt dazu
aufgerufen influenza zu werden und sein
eigenes umfeld mit zu beeinflussen
wenn man der meinung ist dass die
maßnahmen die richtigen sind naja also
sagen wir mal das falten von freunden zu
kommentieren finde ich schon schon
sinnvoll
man sollte jetzt natürlich nicht
versuchen irgendwie ein hobby polizist
zu spielen
ich glaube das kommt selten gut an das
haben wir heute auch nicht mache dass
ich danke ihnen jetzt aber für ihre
einsichten aus dieser interessanten
studie und wünschen noch einen schönen
abend und ich will jetzt hier nochmal in
die kommentare so ein bisschen
eintauchen das heißt wenn ihr jetzt lust
hat noch mal zu gucken was wir zu den
kommentaren zu sagen haben bleibt noch
ein bisschen dran weil das sind viele
dabei die jetzt nicht so richtig was
einem thema zu tun haben
so ein bisschen schon einerseits geht es
geht es hier einmal noch mal um die
frage ob tatsächlich junge menschen
schuld sind in anführungszeichen nicht
mitzumachen hat annika leser noch mal
geschrieben ich bin 25 treffen ich mit
niemandem ich gehe nur aus zum einkaufen
und um zum copyshop zu gehen ich glaube
das ist ein lobenswertes verhalten
winfried meint weihnachten wird schön
der hat gut reden ich glaub weihnachten
ist das was man draus macht lieber sind
flieht und das im endeffekt die jedes
jahr an jedem einzelnen so dann hatte
ich gerade noch einen kommentar hier
gesehen
[Musik]
terra titanic meinte auf youtube so
viele sagen ich treffe mich doch nur mit
punkt punkt punkt na ja das problem ist
dass sich diejenigen auch nur mit dem
und den treffen das ist dann quasi
stille post für fortgeschrittene
das stimmt natürlich aber das große
problem sind ja auch eher so die feiern
wo viele menschen zusammenkommen und
dann man gar nicht mehr weiß wer mit wem
und wo hin gegangen ist und das ist dann
quasi sehr schnell in der ganzen
nachbarschaft verteilt
[Musik]
ja ich sehe hier auf youtube viel
widerspruch der these dass es die
jüngeren sind die sich nicht an die
maßnahmen halten
kkb schreibt auch de facto ist es so
dass gerade die 20 bis 30 jährigen sich
besonders gründlichen empfehlung und
regeln halten also bei ihnen weit
weniger infektionen vorherrschen als bei
älteren
das ist glaube ich nicht ganz so einfach
zu sagen das problem oder die
herausforderung ist ja dass der verlauf
bei jüngeren menschen eher mild ist
schon teilweise asymptomatisch das heißt
gar nicht mitkriegen dass sie infiziert
sind und deswegen werden da auch nicht
so viele positiv getestet weil sie auch
eben gar nicht zum test gehen testen
gehen müssen weil sie keine symptome
haben so aber hier noch mal schlimmer
ehrlich gesagt kann ich mir das nicht
vorstellen alle leute von denen ich das
gehört habe dass sie feiern wollen sind
über 50 okay also ich höre hier bei euch
viel widerspruch und noch einen schönen
kommentar zum schluss von uss kelvin bei
einer großen familie einfach meine bahn
treffen
da ist es okay wenn dort mehr als zehn
personen sind aber da immer maske auf
und bei der bahn ist ist ja mittlerweile
auch so dass abstand gehalten werden
muss das heißt kann natürlich den
vorteil haben dass wenn du den onkel
hass den du nicht treffen möchtest du
kannst du ganz ans ende
waggon setzen und dann einfach immer nur
den gang runter denken dass nach jetzt
auch mit euch ich linke euch zu vielen
dank fürs mitmachen fürs zuschauen und
kommentieren und wir sind morgen wieder
für euch da beim neuen leisten
bis dahin macht gut und tschüss
[Musik]